we think our societies and economies
it's clear that things will never be the
same
but we can influence the direction they
take
we have a chance to rebuild for a
greener and healthier future
and that is what the european green deal
is about
our new growth and innovation strategy
europe aims to be the first climate
neutral continent
by 2015. we set out
on this journey already in 2019 today
many countries around the globe are
in an exciting race to zero
and i was delighted that you president
moon announced that korea is also aiming
to be climate neutral by 2050.
even though the finish line is 30 years
away
the race starts now the 2020s
is the make or break decade
and that's why europe has committed to
reduce our emissions
by at least 55 by 2030
compared to 1990 levels
our targets are now written into
europe's first ever
climate law so we are no longer no
longer discussing
if but rather how we to wean ourselves
off fossil fuels europe will be doing
its part
but the reason we are here today is that
we all need
to do our share at cop26 we must
show that we have understood this big or
small
developing or developed we all have to
invest
in a green transition and adapt to the
coming changes
in our climate it is a matter of
self-interest
of mutual interest and of collective
interest
and i'm encouraged by the commitments of
our korean hosts
this includes your plan for an ambitious
ndc update ahead of cop
26 in line with your net zero targets
and your announcement
of an end to overseas call financing
it is this kind of action that can both
inspire and benefit korea's
international partners
my hope for glasgow is that we see even
more nations
committing to reach net zero by
mid-century
and even more importantly that we see
more concrete
plans for how to get there
my commission will adopt a package of
legislation in july
which we call fit for 55. it
will detail out our european policies
to meet our minus 55 percent target for
2030.
of course we all start from different
places
and we have different geographies and
different finance
needs but this is also true within
europe
so we have to overcome these obstacles
on this long journey
we will all have to learn from each
other and europe
is ready to lead and we are also always
ready to share
we're ready to share our ideas and
strategies on climate action
change is never easy but europe has
taken the decision
because mankind can't wait any longer
and we have to do this together it was
wonderful to listen to jane godel
saying that so rightly so the more we
partner for green growth
the quicker and easier it gets for all
the next six months are crucial
for the health and well-being of our
people
and our planet let's work together
you can count on europe thank you very
much president moon
[Music]
you